on roule pas trop vite à bastos wen
abuse pas au masters of war et bastos
à faire ça bien entendu on peut cadrer
vos produits en les insultant
eh bien
elle attend
ouais
ils nous jugent
tu dois être pas quand on s'arrête
oh
ouais ici déjà white heat et bien
et
[Musique]
oui y'a plein de trucs accroche les gars
vraiment c'est rempli la bon la
course aux voitures les récentes à
orlando orlando je crois
ouais je connais ça bah voila c'est pour
tous
[Musique]
rempotant terre bon voilà en exclusivité
le nouveau bébé de pêcheurs dont ténors
regardez moi cette beauté
un bon petit bébé naissant du site donne
aussi
[Musique]
on a fait les choses en grand qu'est ce
que tu fais un tas d'autres quelque
chose
c'est bien
et a trouvé un trésor elle creuse
j'espère que l'accord va pas te dire que
dans les rochers
pas de bulle
non il faut aller faire la petite
baignade tranquille
qu'est ce qu'il fait c'est à dire il
sort des arbres passe à la pêche
aliments
asta qu'est ce qu'il fait
il a hissé le drapeau
y en a un qui est content
ça c'est du bâton
ça te plaît ce qui t'a offert ton temps
avec bt à faire des tout petits bouts
mais sûrement alors [ __ ] le bois
ok
robin le puzzle avance
beaucoup sympa pendant ce temps ça va
plonger là bas
ouais ça dure
[Musique]
et c'est pas une combine divers donc je
je les
[Musique]
ai
déjà
parlé avec un plâtre est encore dedans
ne pas lui
mais c'est vrai ici
la chaise du pêcheur a plus qu'à
rajouter un petit cieux avec en a déjà
mais c'est parfait derrière ta chaise
[Rires]
ont pu laisser un autre bout encore
c'est incroyable qu'ils se casser la
tête d'affaires des sites hibou île
déserte des voitures mais là une voiture
sans permis après pour transporter les
bouts
alors
ne serait ce pas un bout de voiture
ouais ils ont changé de forme de
morceaux cette fois et en coupe et en
long alors de pêche
mal à marlboro s'il s'appelle à
l'hameçon c'est
d'avoir
incroyable tir au même endroit alors aux
eaux
elle est très près les panneaux de
portes ah non ça va non je m'étais
trompée
elle est belle
de se retirer sans incident et cocasses
ou si des coupes les armes aussi bien
qu'ils découpent les voitures alors en
un seul morceau
c'est la plus belle est encore graisser
asie trouve là bas il y avait des
numéros de série peut-être là souvent
c'est là que lorsque tu es gardien non
mais ils n'ont pu
vous avez été limé bleus puisque c'est
là que tu fais à une grosse série
souvent mais sur l'imparable dernier
mais tavares
a à un panneau
[Musique]
est assez rare en plus
et ils ont tiré à la chevrotine ils ont
fini en noyant quoi
les gens tapaient dans le camion aussi
incroyable c'est une tige pour nettoyer
le talon d'achille en aluminium mais
s'arrête en acier donc on va y voit la
vertu mais lang ou ouais tu vas trouver
le fusil là et on va trouver
et mon petit rasta qui est très sage
c'est bien
ça vient
ou
les disques et de preuve le marteau il
est énorme
et les pages de là et là j'ai des
disques de trains qui sont encore dans
l'emballage ben c'est parfait ils vont
pas sûrement 307 haye quel droit
du coup je crois qu'il est guéri si j'ai
quelque chose
ah oui
c'est la chambre
à il est vraiment bon état
et du coup il ya une lame de charger la
whey donc c'est pas un mono coup
c'est un petit calibre semblerait
intéressant ah ouais +95
c'est stylé cette idée du pt là
où elle a aussi ses produits
connectables c'est quoi ça l'adjoint de
oui oui là
c'est le petit encore ouais mais
pareilles à des neuf
enfants l'ont
regardé elle ressort encore il est tout
aussi certain rexel
lâche et oui comme ça
ça fait plaisir
ça notre caster continue attention son
barrage
el mundo le pp
j'ai pas ça vient peut-être bois ou
peut-être que c'est un arbre tu vois
mais peu drôle
ego la wii
était le prénom c'est autre chose
c'est quoi ça
ça c'est plus vieux ça avance
[Rires]
un peu derrière
ouais je suis aussi
[Rires]
à l'égard
à la porte et on l'a pas découper un ils
ont plié d'écrevisses résister au rush
hop
voilà un peuplier mais si vous avez une
idée de ce que c'est un commentaire
ouais c'est du camion ça je pense est
grande on s'appelle déjà ça c'est pour
l'avenir ça grenadière n'ont rien à dire
je crois que c'est ça ouais deux
morceaux d'armes voilà donc ouais on ne
sait pas ce qu'on pense qu'ils en ont
mis un peu partout
morteau et oui ça c'est pourquoi le
pontet ouais c'est cool on va finir par
le faire le salon et si fait en bus nous
sorte une pension j'ai
[Rires]
bien joué les gars là-bas ya les
sportifs qui font les morceaux de
voiture et nous on fait des armes
bons petits morceaux
ah ouais là ils ont démonté abbas a
abaissé pour nettoyer box est toutefois
aisément
tu va choper les petites vis comme ça
qui se fait chair tout démonter
maison-mère de ouais ça alors attendons
aussi à
ossun pas
il a pris au
sérieux
non je regarde tout gagné
et du bus alors là
une lanterne dans
pareil hein je l'avais pas celui là
[Rires]
roger 1.781 non
comme ils ont tordu
le canon
s'est plaint canon
ouais c'est un plomb on dirait où l'on
plonge 22 long rifle
alors ils marchent plus là
un petit problème là
ah ouais non faut y aller ouais il
voulait vraiment la détruire c'est lui
la voulait vraiment se débarrasser de
son arme
les mêmes manque plus que le cadavre
alors ils étaient en train de ranger et
anton nous a sorti celui ci donc c'est
plutôt drôle oui là encore lent poules
et les filaments au lard encore bon on
essaiera de l'enlever et de voir si
elles marchent à oujda quoi les deux là
hélas trop nul votre jeu
franchement bon
rasta en valais la maison on a même
péché c'est bien baigner
on va j'espère que cette vidéo vous aura
plu pour nous c'était super comme d'hab
c'est un peu le platier
on a une voiture dans une voiture
sympa
mais du coup on dépose les boudins
c'était juste pour s'en débarrasser
taclé voulait plus chez lui mais bon
sait jamais ça peut péter pace des
morceaux qui sont catégorisées je ne
peux pas non plus et garder on en aurait
rien fait toute manière ils ont cassé la
plupart ont peut-être ça servira dans
une enquête